we're joined today by members of autism
Speaks and by members of the McGovern
Institute leadership board by friends
and McGovern Institute's faculty members
of the McGovern Institute's we have a
full range of are both researchers and
supporters here just a bit about the
McGovern Institute it was founded 10
years ago here at MIT by patent Lori
McGovern and very pleased that Padma
governess is here with us today and it
was founded with a dual mission which is
to understand the brain and then to
apply that knowledge gained through
basic research in the brain apply it to
helping people affected by many
different forms of brain disorders and
autism has become a major major area of
interest for us several of our faculty
members have taken up research programs
in in autism and I'm very pleased to say
that the people who have taken up this
interest in autism research are all
people that began in basic neuroscience
just just understanding the absolute
fundamentals of how the brain worked and
in the course of their work they both
saw exciting possibilities for applying
their knowledge to helping people with
autism and they had the opportunity here
to pursue those ideas we've been aided
by many many supporters of course
support from the federal government but
also from many private supporters and
foundations including the Ellison
Foundation and I know that some of the
people here today our families that have
participated in some of the Ellison
supported research studies in the
imaging center and you're going to be
hearing from Nancy kanwisher a little
later who directs some of the Ellison
studies as well as John Gabrielli
who I will tell you about in just just a
moment today I also want to say just a
bit about myself on the Bob DeSimone I'm
the director of the McGovern Institute
and I spent my almost 25 years of my
scientific career at the National
Institutes of Health and Bethesda and
when I left I was a scientific director
for the National Institute of Mental
Health and I decided that it was time to
leave the government support of research
labs and joined the McGovern Institute
because I had become completely
frustrated by the pace of research on
that was making progress in psychiatric
disease and I thought that we needed to
both back to basics go back to the
laboratory where people were doing the
kinds of studies where new ideas would
emerge and I wanted to take what I had
learned to apply to that and to help
people see the possible implications of
what they were doing in the lab for the
clinical research effort and to see if
we can't push that feel forward and that
was the best career decision of my life
to make that transition and I'm the some
of the really exciting work that's taken
place in just a few years of some of the
work that you're going to hear about in
just a few minutes but now I'd like to
introduce Michael Rosen off who's here
from Autism Speaks he's the associate
director for public health research and
scientific review at Autism Speaks he's
a member of the Autism Speaks idealogy
team manages the organization's
epidemiology and public research public
health research grants he's taking the
lead and overseeing the autism
international autism epidemiology
network and part of the team for the
global autism Public Health Initiative
prior to going to Autism Speaks he was
conducting research at Columbia
University is a neurodevelopmental
disorders neuroscience research and he
brings that background in neuroscience
research to
ooh this great effort of autism speaks
to support research directly in this
field so Michael I turn this over to you
thank you so much and good afternoon
everyone I just want to start by saying
it's really truly an honor for me to be
here speaking at MIT and McGovern
Institute in fact as many of you
probably saw I crushed my way in here
and I made it slowly up to the mic not
even the most severely of broken pinky
toads could keep me from talking at MIT
today so again it is really great to be
here mm-hmm so today I'm going to talk
about a subject that's been in the media
a lot lately you can't turn on the news
and hear a report about autism and not
hear them talk about autism prevalence
and how its increase over the years I
when my cousin was diagnosed with autism
22 years ago now nobody knew what it was
even when we heard that he was diagnosed
with autism we didn't know what it was
so even within my family it was just a
completely new term a new disorder to us
but today I mean 20 years later it would
be very difficult for you to go out and
ask somebody if they had not heard of
what autism is I think if you were to
ask somebody if they knew somebody with
autism chances are they would say yes
and and so I'm going to talk about that
today and and what we've seen in the
recent literature is that autism affects
1 in 110 children in the United States
today these are numbers published by the
CDC that's about 1% of the children in
this country this also represents a
fifty-seven percent increase in just
four years of data collection you may
remember it was 1 in 150 before it
became 1 in 110 and that is a quite an
increase in a short amount of time but
if you look at the data over 20 years of
research publications you actually see
that autism prevalence has increased
about six hundred percent over 20 years
again these are the numbers published in
the data so
20 years ago it affected approximately 1
in 2,500 children and again today it's
almost one percent of the population but
the question that we keep hearing is is
this a true rise in autism prevalence is
it a true increase is it real so what
does this mean and that's what I'm going
to talk about today some of the new
research coming out of the United States
data in California in particular that
tries to decipher what this increase in
autism prevalence really means and so
one of the reefs one of the studies that
came out showed how actually over time
the change in diagnostic criteria for
autism may have accounted for some of
this increase more specifically it was
the change in diagnosis from mental
retardation to autism so that those two
circles I mean this has taken a little
bit out of context but this picture
appears in the in the report and what it
shows is that that overlap is the new
autism cases actually resulting from
that shift and diagnosis from mental
retardation and to look at it a little
bit differently what you can see here is
thats that dark slope at the bottom is
the expected change due to diagnose the
expected change in autism prevalence
over time due to that shift from mental
retardation diagnosis to autism
diagnosis but what we saw here was that
extremely large increase so that grey
area is the unexpected rise and what the
researchers from this investigation said
was that about twenty six percent of the
increase in autism prevalence over that
time period in California could be
attributed to changing broadening
diagnostic criteria also coming from
that research lab what we saw was this
idea we've heard of this idea of maybe
the rise in autism prevalence could be
due to an increase in awareness of
autism or better understanding of autism
and so what this paper demonstrated was
that actually the proximity of a child
living to a previously diagnosed child
with autism actually increased that
child's odds of being diagnosed
themselves so the theory here is that
there's some kind of social mechanism
taking place where there's this
information diffusion or sharing of
information within the community that's
actually increasing a child's odds of
being diagnosed with autism so in a way
it's saying that awareness is
contributing to the rise
and the investigators in this study
estimated that sixteen percent of that
rise and autism prevalence could be
attributed to this increase awareness or
information diffusion within the
community also recently in the
literature we've heard about parental
age of being a potential risk factor for
autism parental age we do know is a risk
factor for birth defects and other
neurodevelopmental disabilities but in
terms of autism we're seeing
consistently again that parents over the
age of 40 are at significantly higher
risk for having a child with autism than
their younger counterparts and you can
see here the two dark the gray and the
black lines actually are the the fathers
and the mother's age the risk for
fathers and mothers over the age of 40
whereas that white bar is the the
average risk among the population of
parents actually 25 years 25 years of
age or younger and so what these
investigators came to the conclusion was
that eleven percent of that increase
over time of that slope that we saw
could actually be attributed to this
increase in parental age as a risk
factor now the mechanism for that is
still something under investigation it
may have to do to to genetics but the
idea is that in general parental age is
a risk factor and it can account for
eleven percent of the increase and
parental age is a social component right
parents are choosing to have children
later in life so it's a social factor
that's contributing to the increase so
just to review what I what I went over
and what the research literature is
showing us today is that again twenty
six percent of the increase in
prevalence can be attributed to changes
in diagnostic practices that broadening
criteria sixteen percent is due to
greater awareness and eleven percent is
due to increase in parental age well if
you add that up there's still about
fifty percent of that increase in autism
prevalence that is due to unknown
factors and so the question is of course
well what then is causing the increase
in autism prevalence well I wish it was
a simple answer but it's not what we do
know is that genetic susceptibility is
likely involved in in most cases but
then environmental factors also
contribute to one's genetic
susceptibility and so what we know is
that it's a calm
flex interaction between genes and
environment that are likely causing the
rise in autism prevalence but we need to
identify those factors and understand
exactly how they're contributing to the
increase so I'm going to talk a little
bit about what authors and speaks is
doing to to help understand this and one
of the things we did recently was with
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention we held a workshop in
February first in Atlanta that actually
wanted to look at this change in autism
prevalence over time we wanted to
identify promising directions and
priorities in the research and there was
just a general need among the community
for understanding what this increased
means it's very likely that new
prevalence estimates will come out this
year from the CDC I don't know what the
numbers will be but there's a high
likelihood that those numbers may be
higher so it's it's about time that you
know the federal government was able to
take a position here and hold this
workshop and we were happy to to help
them bring together the right scientists
advocates and individuals with autism to
serve as expert panelists in this
discussion and the key outcomes were
that we need new analytic models for
understanding how these multiple risk
factors actually work together to
increase one's risk for autism how gene
environment work together also there's a
need for better defined autism phenotype
data and that is the autism spectrum
disorders a broad spectrum it's often
said that no two cases of autism are
exactly alike so there's a need for
better better phenotyping better
characterization of the cases in the
data and then of course data quality it
just in general is of course a key
Austin speaks is also funding research
on all of these areas that are appearing
here and to date often speaks has
committed over 160 million dollars to
autism research through the year 2014
and just to give you an idea of where
we're fundings in this research I picked
the Greater Boston area for obvious
reasons but 32 grants from the Greater
Boston area from 10 institutions are
currently being funded at about 7.5
million dollars from Autism Speaks and
you can actually learn about these
grants this is a little plug for a brand
new grant sir judge grants that autism
because org but what I did here was I
wanted to check out what we were funding
to MIT and their two projects that we're
funding here that you can see below
Autism Speaks is also interested in
understanding what prevalence is like
around the world right now the research
suggests that about one percent of
global population has autism however
there have been no studies conducted
outside of these high-income developed
countries that you can see in blue we
have no idea what the Austin prevalence
is in the developing world or even
middle income countries so what we're
doing is we're working with
investigators and exploring
opportunities to look at what is causing
the rise in autism prevalence in over 30
countries around the world through a
number of our programs are international
epidemiology network and our global
autism Public Health Initiative and the
reason why we're doing this is because
international research creates unique
opportunities to investigate genetic and
environmental factors for instance maybe
in some countries there are
environmental factors that are common
where they're not so common here in the
United States at the same time there may
be certain populations that are very
genetically related and there may be
opportunities to find rare genetic
mutations among those populations in
addition it gives us a place to study
creative diagnostic and intervention
strategies among underserved populations
even here in the United States children
are not getting the services that they
require and that they need so by being
for example if you were able to train
parents for instance in heavy provide
intervention in the home we may be able
to use that as a model not only in the
developing world where there aren't
trained professionals to do that but
also here in the United States where
people are don't have access to the
appropriate services so what does it all
mean well the autism crisis is real and
growing it's clear that regardless of
whether or not autism prevalence has
increase over time 1% of the population
is huge there are more children today
diagnosed with autism than ever before
and half of that increase that we saw
over time is still unexplained it's not
caused by just better diagnosis greater
awareness and social factors alone there
are genetic and environmental factors at
play and we need
to understand those environmental
factors and to do that Autism Speaks has
committed 160 million dollars in
research funding but we still need
answers and a better response to this
public health crisis we still need more
funding to do this work just to give you
an idea what i mean by public health
challenge autism prevalence as i said is
101 and 110 in the US type 1 diabetes
one in four hundred childhood cancer one
in two thousand cystic fibrosis one and
3500 so this year more children will be
diagnosed with autism than those other
conditions combined and the annual cost
in the US are an estimated thirty five
billion dollars to society and for each
individual with autism about three
million dollars over their life span so
we need better detection effective and
affordable care there's a growing adult
population in need of support the cost
to society as you see our immense but
the cost of families themselves are
measurable and so just to conclude a
call to action 1 in 110 children have
autism in the United States today about
1.5 million individuals many of which
are underserved what we do know is that
early diagnosis and early intervention
are the keys to improving long-term
outcomes and lifetime costs and autism
and additional research funding is
absolutely essential to finding the
answers to the increase in autism
prevalence and to provide services to
the millions affected by autism in our
country and so with that I just want to
say thank you for your support and again
it's a real honor to be here and I look
forward to the question and answer
period thank you
Michael so we now have two short faculty
presentations and that will be followed
by a open discussion and we're keeping
the faculty presentation short so we can
spend more time in the discussions let
you have a chance to ask questions and
get really engaged people and Nancy
kanwisher will be leading that leading
that discussion but our next speaker is
swapping Feng hua ping is someone who
has established many many of the most
important phenomena of what we know
about the synapses synapses are the
connections between neurons it's how
neurons communicate and he has spent the
early part of his career working out all
the different proteins that interact in
the synapse and in the course of doing
that work he made some really exciting
discoveries that led to a model of
autism that was just published in Nature
and rather than go on and on about this
i will let walk ping tell you about this
himself away and I didn't mean to say
that wapping is the poitras chair of
neuroscience and McGovern Institute and
it's a chair that was established by
Jimmy Pat poitras who've been very
strong supporters of research and
psychiatric illness and Jim and Pat are
also here today so whopping
welcome to my god so we might ever going
to see how our brain builder and the
machinery for communicating between
neurons this is basically the building
block our brain function we have
buildings of neurons in the brain and we
have you know trillions could have
connections the i will bring
communicating very precise away so
that's why we can you know sink and
doing things very precisely and so you
can imagine that there are many
different ways to build can actually
just like a wire computer in neurons the
commuters through this very little
apparatus called synapses they're
basically to neuron linked together they
have a structure and they have hundreds
of hundred proteins actually to help
them to do their work so each little
synapse is about a couple of microns so
very very small but as they are over a
sound and proteins clustered over there
to do the function so there are so many
proteins it means that these are very
you know functional very diverse do they
do a lot of things but it also is the
trouble spot light so any of these
proteins goes wrong genetic mutations
are whatever the factors you know and we
just heard and could cause a problem for
neuronal communication so they are
recently there are a lot of genetic
human genetic studies from patients
suggest that the evidence converge onto
one of the biggest one of the biggest
factors that could have contributed to
autism is synaptic function because many
of the genes meeting you found the all
player many of them are player role at
the synapse so in my lab we study
housing app development develop and how
they function have they are modulated so
during that course and we found that the
genes are critical for the process of
synaptic development and if we just wrap
it up if they're mutations that will
lead to a dysfunction of synapse at
dysfunction neuronal communication now
this in in humans can call security
disorders in mice we cannot diagnose
them autism are OCD but we can't I
diagnose them was
phenotypes their behavior like you know
similar to some of the subtitle
phenotypes of autism are OCD are bipolar
disorders so we are particularly
interesting that this is a synapse can
you see when you are communicated to
another nua so we are particularly
interesting a group of proteins that in
this side of the communication the
receiving side we call the post an epic
side of the synapse and so some of the
proteins are have been implicated in
many several psychiatric disorders and
I'm going to focus on one protein which
you know there are very strong evidence
human genetic evidence called shanks
oops so this protein is basically my
mouse disappeared ah here we go so this
is the protein which is linked the
important proteins ion channels from
memory from the synapse to the membrane
so to the cytoskeleton so and so one
particularly we are interested in this
is you called on the left right side
called a shank sweet because this
protein for reason we study them because
there are many line evidence suggested
that in one particular bring area called
striatum which is in the middle of the
part of the brain and no okay so enough
in this stock pack of the brain which is
the striatum so this highly expressed
there and the dysfunction has been
implicated in many psychiatric
especially in OCD and autism oh thank
you and so this part of brain so they
are also why we're studying this try to
understand how this protein function
apps in the neuronal communication there
are quite a few clinical studies show
this gene actually mutation of this gene
is very strongly linked to autism they
are actually hundred the patient with is
the deletion of gene or mutation in this
gene and so there is a large-scale study
recently very recently published
suggests they're about point seven to
one percent of ASD patient actually
contain this mutation in this gene so
it's a very
significant fact you because a contest
study have not identified a very
significant allele for any of the
psychiatric disorder so this is a we
started this is the most likely a
monogenic factor and many others that
may not be monogenetic about is by study
I'm all organic a case it will help us
understand what is really wrong in the
brain of these patients all these then
can help us to understand you know what
are the making how can we crack this and
this could have if we understand this
magazine we could have a broader
impacting understand what other artistic
patient may have in their pathological
brain so we our studies by generating
mutant mice I archant you all know have
three major of you know core symptoms
reparative compulsive behavior sometimes
or injures and they have language
impairment and they have social
interaction deficit because it's very
hard to to study language I don't know
where they speak english chinese or
friendship don't understand but there
are things we can study in mice right
for example if every behavior so when we
mutant this gene they have repetitive
compulsive grooming they grew me their
skin and he'll here and skin of this
teal group is so self injurious grooming
and most important they have a you know
myself social animals you can study
their social behavior actually very
easily so these the animal actually they
don't like social these are you know
scientifically okay i can show you a
video that they don't like actually a
social with other mics so i'm going to
show you two videos this is video and
showing just put them this is one just
put it to my and you know a few mice in
your cage learn how they you know
interact with each other so this side is
the Y type you know just regular this is
a mutator with shank sweet and then you
will see when no i need to find the
mouse otherwise so you can see that when
you put vice together right so initially
they were you know pretty soon they will
get together to interact so this is
mutant mice these white I mice and so
even so in the white time I just start
to you know sniffing and the static
start to play but you look at this
mutant mice they always stay by them so
do do whatever you like this smells we
still there digging for you know all the
time right
my time I they we start interacting with
each other with sniffing and the player
one I know where they're talking about
that they are playing right so these you
can see the whole time you videotaping
them they actually never get together
they would do the summer they are active
doing something but they are the patio
doing something and just not an
interesting interact with other mice so
and the next video I'll show you is that
if you put a novel object into this this
is all so happy that you humans and yeah
they're afraid of the novel object so
this isn't you basically put a new toy
in their home cage right so this time
that time this side is muting device
this is a white I'm ice so when you put
this in and you will see very peculiar
phenomenon so this is why type you can
see the goal passing by and eventually
they will get stiff and go on this you
see they are very scared you're getting
close they will startle back and it just
never touch it so this eventually you
will see this sniffing and they've
started getting play the new toy so this
mutant mice you can see the running
around them and look at them and really
scared of it there's nothing you know
it's not hot or cold or anything it's
just a new toy so tell you this might
actually have a phenotype of afraid of
you know phobia of the Normandy so same
thing for novel IQ amount you put a new
normal mice thing it would completely
avoid so these are phenotype of the
Quick Sync we can characterize so the
kissing to a neurobiologist try to
understand this type of behavior is why
why you mutated a single gene what
having these mice have this peculiar you
know deficit which is resembling some of
the phenotypes in symptoms in autistic
patient so the idea is to animals you
can do a lot of you know Advanced
Studies use used biochemical study
electrophysiologist study you can look
look at a bring activity located
communication so a particular particular
area we interesting the our community
within context to the striatum which is
a very area strongly implicated in
autism and OCD so when we look at them
indeed the neuron your communications is
very severely disrupted so we think that
is
other evidence such as this is the key
to to the this defect is the key to the
repetitive behavior composite because if
you if you put a Jing back only in that
area you can actually rescue the
repetitive behavior so and the
interesting for autism for this autism
model is we also see structural defect
in neurons they actually have a much
complex than you are a neuronal
structure and they have more they are
neurons more complex there are more
processes so that got us interested
because in human patients you're
probably very clear where they're one of
the most robust finding autistic kids is
they have an English debris it's not
every kids but it's very significant so
actually we did a 3d volumetric
structure mi study to show actually will
show that in these mice in the mutant
mice they are stratum they are caught it
is also enlarged so it's a similar to
what we found in human piece are you
human patients so suggesting there's
some of the neuronal structure change in
the brain at the individual neuron level
may contribute to this phenomenal we
found in these mice so the idea is that
by study this you can understand we can
understand what a structure is defective
on what type of defective let's give you
a way to find find an approach to
correct them in mice first and hopefully
that will lead us to in the future to
test these hypotheses in patient right
for example we don't know what caused a
social deficit but there are many series
not with this mice with such a robust
the social deficit we can test them so
in my lab we're testing how can cracker
is associate deficit what is which part
of brain region actually responsible so
we can put a gene back or use chemical
where you struggle to to a correct this
problem can we reverse this associate
deficit so this kind of study or have
hopefully what happens in the future
although we are doing in a lab in a very
very basic research and you use any
wiser model we're hoping by combining
human genetic studies with with the gene
mutated known cause autism human patient
or help us to find a way to improve our
understanding of hopefully future
develop a new strategy for treatment so
that's I'm going to stop here these are
the people I didn't do any of this work
these other people did am i working
thank you we're going to hold questions
shortly so the next person presenting is
John Gabrielli John was recruited govern
Institute from Stanford and is also the
head of our imaging center which you
will be invited to take a tour of at the
at the time of the reception John is
another person started out in this
career studying the basic biology of the
brain how neural circuits support memory
formation and as he began extending his
work into child development and
emotional development and so on he took
up an interest in autism disorders and
he's going to be telling us about some
of the work that they're doing in human
subjects in the imaging center as part
of the autism project John
my mighty consult any problems have to
switch from Apple to a pc thank you
I know now you gonna be disappointed
sorry all right thank you III have one
another one ya think
thank you very much okay it's a pleasure
and honor to speak in this program it's
a tremendous privilege to do research at
MIT and to work in the McGovern
Institute for brain research the
scientific inspiration of my peers the
technical support through the remarkable
in my area imaging center downstairs
which together the Meg center the MRI
machine erp resources really make every
major method we have for non-invasively
looking at the human brain available to
all researchers in a small space
comfortable for research participants
it's really a huge privilege in the
philanthropic support that helps us
advance as a much greater right we would
otherwise it's a huge privilege and a
huge responsibility so I'm tell you a
little bit about some of our research
recently on looking at in humans at
brain disorder aspects of autism and
we're all struck by that I think those
of us who work on typical brain
functions as well as difficulties and
brain functions about the fragile power
of the human brain the capacity to feel
a dream desire remember and move
socially interact on the other hand
every one of those powers has an
Achilles heel in the brain or risk you
know when you see a thousand protein
sitting around and one tiny synapse as
we heard so eloquently before there's
such it's so amazing on the one hand and
it's so risky on the other and also the
sense that work on developmental
disorders the neurodevelopmental lottery
that every infant and child and family
participates in the large number of
individuals who will be born with
something that will make life
challenging for them and something that
we want to do better about to help us
children flourish and families flourish
and so as you heard and you know autism
is typically defined as involving three
areas of difficulty or difference in
social interaction and communication and
repetitive behaviors the research I'm
about to describe today is on
individuals who would have the diagnosis
of Asperger's or higher functioning
autism that line is about to be erased
in this in dsm there could be all kinds
of discussion about what that means or
doesn't mean on the one end and
it's going to be erased on the other end
supposedly for pdd-nos and you know we
can discuss maybe this you know what we
think about that but but anybody'd sort
of broadens the spectrum and what we
understand to be a spectrum of disorder
and difficulty for the kind of research
I'm describing today all of our research
tends to focus on individuals who are
strong or cognitive Ian language because
they need to understand instructions go
into scanners and we're all acutely
aware that in many ways our research
efforts under serve individuals who are
for example non-communicative and that's
something we think about a fair bit as
well and I have tremendous thanks for
the research participants and families
and for the initial sources of support
that let this research get done and
we're also aware that individuals and
families dealing with autism you know
they have a full and challenging life
and to take the time and effort to come
and participate in research we're very
grateful none of this would happen
without that kind of participation so
I'm going to focus on some behavioural
finding and a couple findings of using
brain imaging and I'm going to focus on
studies about a in that experiment
theory of mind and that's the ability to
attribute mental states such as beliefs
desires and knowledge to oneself and
others and to understand that others
have beliefs desires and intentions that
are different from one's own it's
basically the capacity to imagine that
other people's minds are can have
different perspectives full of feelings
thoughts and plans at the end that they
can differ not only from our own
thoughts and feelings but perhaps even
from the physical reality around us and
it's been known for quite some time the
development of theory of mind so a child
becomes sort of adult like around six or
seven on many of the kinds of tasks
where they have to think including by
the way deception is all theory of mind
is delightful and about understanding
other people that you knowing how to
deceive other people depends upon
understanding what they are willing to
believe is possibly true so if it's the
full complexity of human relations are
captured in the understanding of what
other people think and that for many
years has been shown that a adult-like
theory of mind is delayed even in
individuals with high-functioning ASD
you know five six seven years
the measure but behaviorally there's
been kind of a mismatch which is that in
high functioning adults adolescents and
so on the kinds of tasks developed for
children are successfully performed and
so you have a mismatch between the kinds
of everyday practical real reports that
the families and individuals tell you
which is it's a bit challenging to talk
to people i don't understand really
where they're coming from i might say
the wrong thing i don't know what
feeling they have and how to best
address that and you know doing very
well in these tasks of theory of mind
and that's because many of these tasks
were originally developed in fact all of
them to start with we really originally
developed for young children that's
where the literature came from
originally and so a high-functioning
adolescent or adult knows the correct
answer and we can't study in science
what we can't measure we can't begin to
analyze and understand something if we
can't measure in the laboratory so we
want to be able to measure in some way
experimentally this challenge and
understanding or just difference in
understanding what's in the minds of
somebody else and so together with a
Rebecca sakshi I'm young and Joe Moran
we looked into the realm of moral
judgment to kind of develop eight what
you might call a stress test a more
challenging test of thinking about
what's in the mind of somebody else and
how you value that or way that in your
own analysis of what's going on so we
focused on the difference between
intentional harm when you mean to harm
somebody an accidental harm when harm
occurs but you didn't mean to do it and
failed attempts and so we kind of put a
stress or a competition between two
things and all you'll see the concrete
example the outcome whether something
good or bad happened and the intention
whether you meant something good or bad
to happen and by putting those things in
opposition for example accidental harm
innocently you do something but
something bad happens to somebody well
now we put them there's no bad intention
but there's a bad outcome so individuals
read a series of stories would have
roughly this property sometimes they
would be told that an individual thinks
powder is for example as toxic it is
toxic you give it to you a friends and
she dies these are very rough stories
but they're just little stories and
everybody agrees you know grace was bad
okay that bad is morally impermissible
to do that if grace passes sugar the
sugar is fine nothing happens everybody
says there's no moral problem to be
weighed here no problem the two issues
were the two situations where we put
intentions and outcomes into opposition
are these other two conditions where
grace thinks the powder of sugar its
toxic and the friend died so she passes
a sugar too so okay intention that
outcome or that intention she thinks
it's toxic she passes the sugar but
nothing that happens so she in these two
cases there's kind of a stress or
tension between the intention of the
person and the outcome of the Act and
then we asked what happens is people
raped the moral permissibility of these
actions so in this graph the higher than
the value is the more you think it's
morally permissible to do things and the
first thing to notice is that these high
functioning individuals with autism
spectrum disorder you know pretty much
look similar in most cases as you might
expect in making these judgments nothing
if something very bad happened and it
was intentionally done everybody agrees
that's very bad nothing bad happened
everybody agreed no problem where
something happens this here so typically
developing individuals neurotypical
individuals forgive accidental harm and
keep in mind that something bad happened
right in this story but they say well if
he didn't mean it it wasn't so bad
individuals with a diagnosis of autism
don't forgive it so much there's not a
right or wrong answer on this you know I
mean these are stories in a laboratory
you're telling a story you know if it's
my relative and somebody accidentally
does something terrible to them you know
i'm not sure i'd be as forgiving on the
intention there's not a right answer to
this there's a wayne of how to think
about a complex moral situation and so a
chance for us to be able to measure the
weighing of outcomes versus intentions
and intentions reflect theory of mind
right understanding what a person meant
that's a test or direct measure of that
so we're hoping this will help us a have
a way to better measure differences in
how people approach thinking about
situations and then be able to
examine whether for example certain
kinds of treatments affect this early on
that might be helpful to individuals let
me switch 22 results from brain imaging
and in this experiment with Elizabeth
read k who's now on the faculty of
Maryland we looked at the difference of
what happens when you look at somebody's
looking directly at you versus somebody
whose gaze is averted and as you know if
you talk to somebody it's a very
different social experience that they're
looking at you or if while you're
talking to them there eyes are over here
the gaze is averted right you know that
they're paying attention to something
else it's a different social
communication and so we had adolescents
with or without the diagnosis of ASD see
in different situation conditions face
looking right at you or a face looking
away and again the face looking at you
we think is you know as a person's ready
to do social communication with you an
averted face of somebody who's towards
you suggesting they're shifting their
attention somewhere else some things
more interesting they're not interested
in you it's a different social cue and a
very fundamentally keep social cue we
found in typically developing adults as
to brain areas that responded in
opposite ways to where the gaze was
directed so that if they were looking at
averted gazes activation in the
posterior part of the superior temporal
sulcus the parrot the posterior temporal
sulcus is a big brain region but it's
been implicated in social cognition
thinking about how people are talking
looking moving their mouth lots of
aspects of social cognition and you
might imagine that what's going through
your mind if you're talking to somebody
and they're looking that way right
you're thinking that why are they not
listening to me you know what's going on
right so we're you know this is some
sort of a response to that that the
antisocial signal you're getting from
somebody in contrast in the insides and
the medial prefrontal cortex the region
involved and often respond to how other
people are thinking more response the
opposite direction when somebody's
looking at you then looking away so we
don't really know what this means until
there's you know how to think about this
in a deep way but you know perhaps you
know this is a part of the brain that
gets engaged when you're thinking your
head
a direct social interaction and some
exchange of mental pathway or sharing of
thoughts and when we look at individuals
in the same age range very
high-functioning very smart individuals
with with the diagnosis of autism here's
what we see minimal difference in the
posterior cortex and also minimal
difference in the medial prefrontal
cortex how to interpret that you know is
a long step to go but but much less
sensitivity as far as we can measure in
the brain for differentially responding
to these two kinds of social cues both
the eyes towards you and the eyes
averted I'm going to present two more
slides with two more results uh one of
the striking things in the literature
again this is always with individuals
who are who are very cognitively
functioning well is this this which is
an observation that in the laboratory
again sort of like with the theory of
mind that people do very well on these
kinds of tests we give them and then
they say yeah but in real life is really
challenging and one of the things that
happens in the experiments we do in the
laboratory is we've unusually sort of
well-organized formatted conditions you
know we say get ready you're going to do
X that's not like life where you're
walking around things happen right we
also get ready to be social ok ok thank
you know yeah so because that's how
experiments are they're not like real
life and so uh on the other hand we have
to know if that's how we do science so
one thing that's been noted is this and
there's you know this is bill done work
from Nancy kanwisher who discovered the
fusiform face area the first area in the
brain selectively response to face is
compared to all other visual stimuli and
some researchers have said well it's
kind of a messy literature on what
happens in this part of the brain a
complicated literature but some people
have said well if you can you know
sometimes we get less response in this
area and it's the data is all over the
place actually when we show faces but if
we put and this is not our work from
Boston u verse if you wouldn't red dot
to draw the attention of the individual
to the face to focus them you know by
this little manipulation then we don't
see any difference between typically
developing young adults and adults with
ASD
uh so and they said well when we see
differences maybe it's because what's
spontaneously individuals with ASD tend
to do but if the stimulus draws them in
then the response is similar so we just
wanted to ask does that seem correct
okay because that experiment involved
one experiment had some experiments that
faces without any red dot one experiment
had red dots only and we were going to
say in the same individual if you
present something that draws your
attention to the face versus another
condition where you more freely can
attend to it or not does that make a
difference and we looked in this
fusiform face area on the posterior
cortex and here's what we found for
typically developing adolescents it
doesn't make a difference that is
they're interested in faces in it
doesn't matter whether the dot is there
are not faces are very socially
interesting stimulii for most people for
individuals on the spectrum it makes a
measurable difference and we're only
partway through the study but it looks
pretty looks pretty clear that when the
dot is there to draw the attention than
the response is very much like that of
the typical typically developing control
participants but when it's not there
there's less activation and in some
sense maybe less attention is drawn to
the face so we're not completed with the
study with others as a final thing but
it's something interesting because I
think what's fascinating about it is you
know if a red dot can do that and
there's got to be way so we can help
people you know then they have the
resource available to them how should I
put it first there's some things where
the resources is not available to people
but if a red dot can make a difference
you know the right kind of support make
me people find it much easier to have
social interactions if that's
machineries available to them under the
right context and elastic result they
won't share it with you is where we show
people faces neutral faces or emotional
faces and looked in the structure called
the amygdala it's a structure that's in
the limbic system in response to signals
of threat in the environment or sources
of risk in the environment and here's
what we found and there's a small twist
in the story so if we looked in the
amygdala at the response for emotionally
provocative faces angry of anger or fear
we saw this kind of activation typically
developing young adult
and the absence of that activation in
individuals with ASD and you can stop
right there and you could say well the
amygdala is you know not responding to
faces in some way it's another aspect of
the social processing difference in the
brain by the way we don't see a
difference when we look at responses to
houses so it's a social thing it's not
everything but we can do one more thing
which does not just look at the
difference so this brain activation is a
difference between the emotional faces
and neutral places we can sort of look
at that how the responses aren't in each
condition and what we see is this that
typically developing individuals have a
stronger response for these emotionally
expressive faces that signal threat
anger or fear the neutral faces that's
been found many times before when we
look at the individuals with ASD what we
find is there sort of activator turned
on for both kinds of faces so you don't
see an activation here because this is a
difference between the two and there's
not a difference between the two but
what appears to be having is the
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder are responding in the amygdala
as if the neutral face were as
provocative as a angry or fearful face
so when they get the emotional
expressive face they're sort of no more
were to go there at the top of their
scale already and that might go with a
sense i think that individuals autism
sometimes feel by the report and you
know a sense of stress in dealing with
people and it doesn't you know for for
people without others in distress mostly
happens when people are looking angry at
you are scared at you that's when you
figure something wrong is happening or a
treatment but for individual autism
perhaps you know even the neutral faces
are only triggering a sense of anxiety
that would be you know make it less
desirable perhaps interact with somebody
so the yep I always ended with it just
so story like this we don't know that's
the story we just know the brain signal
but you know we want to think about how
these brain signals might relate to the
everyday experience of individuals so so
thank you very much
so we're going to now we're going to
have our discussion and and then that's
going to be followed by a reception
outside we invite you all to join the
reception and I also want to point out
that this is part of a series that we've
started in brain disorders the McGovern
Institute we are just a few weeks ago we
had a one of these sessions on
depression next fall we have one coming
up in Alzheimer's disease and we hope
that you will stay on our mailing list
take our literature and if you have
registered and allow us to a contact you
will send you notices about upcoming
events and we hope that you'll come to
other events in the future and become
involved with us RS masking Nancy
kanwisher to be the moderator of the of
the next session Nancy as John mentioned
was the person who discovered the Fiza
form face area in the human cortex and
on early on Nancy noticed that believe
it or not our brains are not all
identical and that if you'd even just
take a simple thing like where is the
area that processes faces in your brain
it actually shifts around from person to
person then and and she became a
proponent of the idea that you really
have to study each person individually
their brain and not just average across
large groups of people and assume that
everybody in a big group is the same and
she took this perspective into autism
and said we really need to understand
the whole autistic population at an
individual level because there's almost
certainly going to be different sub
groups of people with autism that are
different and that we shouldn't just be
all averaging them together and she's
initiated a major project and children
trying to understand that individual
variability and to try to uncover the
fundamental features that are shared by
small groups of kids on the autism
spectrum and so she will both moderate
the session but also she is at another
expert in this field and she will answer
questions
as well so glopping and John do you want
to come up here and Michael are you
going to join us up here you willing to
take questions or of course and I'll be
the master some ceremonies
great well welcome it was not this is on
it was a it was wonderful to hear from
all of you even though I've heard from
two of you many times before there's
always new exciting stuff no it was also
really lovely to have michael's
introduction to the importance of this
problem so so just to get things rolling
i'd really like to get questions from
the audience but i'll just start by
pointing out what's probably audit
already obvious to most of you is a
incredible fascination and challenge and
importance of studying autism so
beautifully underlined by by michael's
presentation of the fact that the
incidence is skyrocketing and that only
some of that increased incidence is
attributable to understandable factors
like changes in the diagnosis raising
this real importance and challenge of
understanding what's going on to change
this incidence but you can also see the
fascination and challenge of the huge
breadth of different levels of analysis
that we have an autism research with go
pings magnificent work on the shank
three protein one of those thousand
proteins at the synapse and in this
incredibly intricate structure in the
brain bridging all the way from there
too in humans this the very high level
phenomenon of the triad of symptoms in
autism and the kind of phenomena that
John talked about with specific social
disorders so to me one of the real
challenges is how we go how what kind of
causal explanation can we come up with
that bridges from a particular gene or a
particular protein in the synapse all
the way up to a high-level social
deficit in autism how do you go from a
gene to a very specific social disorder
and that's just a scientifically in the
abstract it's a magnificent mystery and
in the case of autism it's a pressing
need to understand that causal chain and
of course we need to understand that
causal chain in order to understand how
to intervene in that system so i guess
i'd like to invite questions from the
audience if it
turn off the projector and turn okay do
you know how to do that just for me
completely
Oh
oh don't lean back
okay Wow all right man was it yes okay
thank you a non-scientific question I I
concur there's been an incredible
increase in the diagnosis of autism in
the last 20 years and is there has been
any studies that all done as far as
correlation between socioeconomic
changes we have gone in the last 50
years into a nuclear society among many
other things and how is there any
correlation at all from having gone not
only from an agrarian to an industrial
but from industrial to a nuclear society
so it is this on can you hear me okay
I'll just hold my tie out time out there
has been some research on the influence
of socioeconomic status on an autism
risk and it does show that higher
socioeconomic families do seem to be at
higher risk for having children with
autism but the question that comes out
of that is is it because that those
families have greater access to
diagnostic and treatment services and so
are they being captured in those
research studies more often than those
of lower socioeconomic status who may
not have access to again diagnostic or
treatment services so the research there
is not definitive but you know the
parental age stuff that's coming out is
a little bit more I mean it's been
repeated and what we're also seeing
among those groups is that families of
older parents of children with autism
are also of higher socioeconomic status
on average so there may be a
relationship there in terms of social
factors working together that increase
the odds of being diagnosed with autism
it may not be a true risk in the sense
though of a you know an exposure for
instance that's causing it
I was I was just curious if some of the
mutations that you saw in mice can be
seen through like MRI or some other
testing like the protein mutation or the
was it the caudate mutation yeah that's
a good question so we are so for the
structure in my you can do almost
identical things that humans and mice
for functional my John just show this
the rest it's possible we are working on
them the resolution is still much lower
because the mouse brain is very small
you know it's so so getting higher
resolution there are different ways to
get a goal yes oh yes it is possible to
do actually we're planning to do it we
just discussed because it was a very
high magnetic field mm I machine down in
the basement and so we are in the next
few months we actually need to do that
but the resolution is still much lower
so you cannot say okay we're not totally
sure you can for you can amygdala in
John's picture is pretty big that's
almost as big as a mouse brain I think
it's awesome so it's a little motive
source of many engineering and
scientists are trying to develop a much
more sensitive ways to do the function
of the neuronal activity and in the
future maybe there you know emmy gee
just designated today and open to the
facility that's another possibility can
directly translate the comparison mouse
and the humans that's a very important
aspect that we are doing i I know that
one of the things that has happened here
as I McGovern is putting something in
that's missing or putting back something
that was mutated and then creating
something is that happening in autism
where you're finding something missing
that you like the protein or some other
gene that you can add back to fix the
problem can you maybe talk about the
rescue expect yeah so yes so they are
there are genetic ways in mice we can
almost do anything you want if the
mutated will put it we if we find a
human mutation whip we can put exactly
same mutation finding human patient into
mouse make a mutant mice you can also
put exactly the same gene
the non mutated the Norma Jeane back in
the human in mice not only in in the
mouse but in the particular brain area
to see if i restore function of this
particular area fergie number omega is
that enough to rescue the full spectrum
are only small I aspect and so this is a
completely possible that actually doing
so in the repetitive compulsive behavior
if we actually didn't expect we put the
protein only back in the striatum that
rescues it not only that you let the
mouse developer this problem have
lesions everything then the adult you
present back a completely cure is it not
only they stop doing this they're skiing
everything heals so it's possible
suggest it's not a divot at least in
some cases they are not a developmental
defect that's not irreversible it's at
least reversible oh it's a actually a
function of defect that you can so that
brings hope if if you know not
everything studied you my skin be
trending human but somehow you do so if
this is trying to weigh the human give
you hope that this can be corrected in
the in the future in humans so it's
definitely possible this result is truly
astonishing I guess probably cleared
already most of you already but just to
underline to me the default assumption
before these recent results of go pangs
and a few other related things in other
labs was just that if if things go wrong
during development well you know there
may be some symptomatic treatment some
ways that you can treat teach people to
work around the problems but you don't
usually think of things as so changeable
in adulthood so this is a this is a
really magnificent and exciting result
yeah sorry there was another question of
here yeah I have 22 pieces I like to
address and maybe you could speak about
it first of all I think part of the
problem with this facial lack of content
is these kids are working so hard just
to figure out where they are so they're
really centered on themselves and
secondly they add trying to figure out
what's going on with their relationship
of the world and if you think about it
we live in a three-dimensional world but
they're actually two-dimensional type
people they're having a hard time
spatially fitting in with the
environment
so that's one of the one thing number
two is they've got circular thinking and
very poor short-term memory which
prevents them from being social to begin
with so the circular thinking you know
impedes any kind of creativeness or
spontaneity or anything like that and
and thirdly back to the speciality
concept what I've seen observed with
many kids over the years is the flapping
the the hand movement it's they're
trying to figure out their bodies in
relationship to the world and it's a
physical question I know if you follow
this but this is what I've observed and
I think if you could really get into the
circuit of thinking I think it would be
great or the repetitiveness because
that's what really impedes them from
being at all spots and spontaneous I
mean what one of the things important
points you're pointing to is to me one
of the real mysteries in autism is which
of these different aspects of the
disorder are related to each other
causally right so so I think you're
suggesting that some of the some of the
difficulties with gays and and and
processing faces may be in fact a result
of other difficulties and I think that's
a really central question it's one it's
one of the ones that we're trying to
investigate in our research program
where we test each kid on an exhausting
number of different behavioral task to
try to figure out which of these things
go together kid by kid and by the way
huge thanks go to the because there's a
few parents here to those of you who
have brought your children in for 23
days of testing which is a huge thing to
ask of parents and we're greatly
appreciative of your participation in
our studies we realize is not a small
thing to come in for three days of
testing but but on that note I was
actually wondering during copings talk
whether the the Phenom the two phenomena
you reported with the shank three mice
the social avoidance and the avoidance
of novelty right on this point do you
think that's one thing or two things
right because it another mouse or
another person is a is a very complex
mysterious kind of unpredictable thing
much as a novel object is and so I
wonder whether that's really two
distinct phenomena can you tell we
we have series so we are testing them so
one of the most interesting I have ever
seen for autistic kids about the study
was you know I tracking and a video for
a luma toys and computed and teaching
front normal kids going you there were
gaze on the teacher and you're looking
at smiling face and chatter would then
start looking what toys I can play
autistic kids going with eye tracking
you know this is our studies show that
they are equally scanning you know
there's no preference for human face
like so so they're kind of really
interesting to me too many other people
why was the artistic you to see human
face and and they've tied and give it
all identical and then it will fix our
oh this is how I wanna head we keep it
plain so one of the theory by funky my
study some of the studies suggest maybe
it's also involved in the rewarding
system you know you interact with people
it's a it's a very rewarding smiling
face so I think passion it's related
that repetitive behavior is most
contributed to the dorsal striatum and
the audience is animosity to that to the
venture so it's a communication between
cortex and reasoning imparted foreign
cortex to destroy them too but in a
different area now in the behavior essay
itself if they are so interested
restricted interested to do something
else just like you said whether they are
you know four of them think about the
other things they mean less there may be
less interesting you know interact with
other human beings so it is possible
they are you know link but I singing to
a certain degree you can separate them
are mechanistically in the brain that's
our how possible testing them at least
in mice to a test them but a function my
you guys also tested by different you
know facial and interactions
so I work on synapses and as go pigs
picture so elegantly showed there are
lots of things going on at synapse if
there are lots of proteins and the
dynamics are incredible their their
position does something you know
singular but things are turning over at
different rates there's protein
synthesis it's at synapses and you could
potentially get defects that sets of
synapses for a variety of reasons so the
the real problem with a disease like
autism is that it's probably not one
thing it could be in some cases one
thing that affects a variety of proteins
a SAP apps scaffold a lot of the
proteins at synapses that and and so
there are lots of things that could be
wrong and and so it it's not even clear
if we had a single gene that we knew was
definitely associated with autism that
we could replace that gene and solve the
problem because there are lots of
regions in the brain that are necessary
to function to work together so it's a
real challenge and it's still a great
unknown there are lots of us working at
synapses now but we're only just
beginning to understand with things like
optogenetics and and and finer ways of
imaging the dynamics of synapses that
that it's it's not just a question of
identified it's a it's a question of
identifying those things that influence
things and and organize them in time so
this is the challenge on a lot of these
diseases it's probably one of the
challenges in schizophrenia to
no I think that really is one of the
problems I think that there is
ultimately there will be many many
causes of autism and whatever sub parts
of autism there will be what I'm
interested in is is there any research
that suggests better or worse ways of
treating people who have these many
problems and disabilities I don't hear
very much about research in that area
you know when you have a stroke people
will tell you what area of the brain is
causing this and then you talk about the
plasticity of the human brain it's
incredible but what about the autistic
people's plastic brains I don't hear
anybody talking about what you do with
the huge numbers of people who are still
so troubled is there an end point we
have an autistic nephew and we don't
know whether to think he's being lazy
often or whether he's being stubborn he
sometimes both but how far do you push
it and it's in that area that I'm most
interested you know what what is being
done to figure out how to best help
these people it's a hugely important
question my though this is not the area
i work in most closely my sense of this
is that still the standard kind of
intensive training methods that have
been the kind of norm and autism for you
know at least 10 or more years are still
thought to be the kind of the best shot
at the moment but i think the kind of
basic research that will ping is doing
does give hope that that you know
changes that happen later in life may be
able to kind of continued advancement I
don't know maybe you guys want to add
that i want to emphasize wincing whether
we trying to do i think many of us
trying to do is we now almost clear from
human genetic studies not that one or
two or even ten genes are contribute to
our tasks to freedom there are many many
genes can contribute to that and each
one each of the list medium it may only
contribute to a very small percent
patient so you have a vie
vast majority variety of different
underlying mutations are factors
contributing combined by environmental
factor than other things but our idea is
for whatever the reason and autumn has
cause symptoms if we think about how
brain works for any particular core
symptom there is must be a calming if
the common symptom their mystic must be
a common neural circuitry activity that
I can show that so if we understand what
a neurotoxic couldn't you a particular
behavior then it doesn't matter what
caused it we can modulate that activity
and to treat a variety of different
patients with a similar genome or
Republicans compulsive behavior your CD
has it automated torretta trick tell me
and the idea is if we really figure out
that the also stratum is the key which
is we have a lot of evidence from human
studies and from animal studies then if
we find a way to correct the problem
then this American can be treated for a
variety of disorders that's the idea
that we we are not going to replace
every single gene in every gene mutation
which is not feasible right now the
ideas understanding your circuits defect
and find a common way to treat it and
you know at least a significant group
problem there may be several different
this subgroup double that's the idea
that's hope that basic animal research
will help to understand them like I said
I think that uh the game-changing
approaches to treatment will come out of
basic neurobiology because that's you
know I also think that people's lives
can be made better without game changers
we want we want the game changers we
have to the basic neuroscience but we
have people now right I'd like you and
there's a practically every childhood
neural developmental difficulty there's
a shocking absence of random assignment
investigations of behavioral
effectiveness of treatments this is this
true of dyslexia of ADHD you know people
are fast for the medications there's a
few widely used behavioral interventions
of the dancing mentioned and you know
about but anything else that might help
you know you hear a lot about cognitive
training or this kind of thing they're
shocking with you
reasonably controlled studies of those
four and I think it's a shame you know
because maybe those things could make
life meaningfully better for people now
but I think physicians parents patients
have very little information in the way
you describe that it's a stunning
absence of research I think part of the
problem is if you have a kid with autism
you're not going to just you know
volunteer for a random assignment you're
going to do everything you have the
resources to do of course and so that
makes it challenging to do those studies
so I completely i understand that of
course you don't but but there's things
you know I've heard of their studies
just now just just beginning amazingly
of things like cognitive training and
young adults okay now does that help
also is it a waste of their time yeah
that's worth knowing yeah and so where
is the study that tells you you know it
might help and maybe help some kind of a
person but on another and it's just
amazing about the absence of evidence
about them we're getting to the end of
our time for the question question
hasn't had a chance to ask
I appreciate the rise and when you take
all the things out old age parents all
that stuff but there's been a rise in
autism of some percentage do any of you
have theories or beliefs in prevention
toxicity I mean all our children you
know BPA in bottles of anything that
parents could be doing do you have any
little gleanings of evidence of
something that might be causing this
that could be involved in chemicals or
toxicity and I'm not going to give it
the answer that you want to hear but in
my mind if the answer is we don't have
those answers we can't give you that
information because the research just
doesn't exist yet there are a lot of
environmental factors of interests that
are being investigated but to date there
aren't any that you can point to and say
these are the ones that are really
contributing to an increase in autism
risk it's partially do because the
research funding isn't there but also
because some of these studies are very
difficult to to undertake you hear
things of studies requiring large sample
sizes or what's called a longitudinal
study prospectively collecting data
there are some projects that are
underway are being planned one being the
National Children's Study that the
federal government is funding for the
most part that will track mother's from
the time of conception all the way
through their pregnancy to birth and
then following those children up to the
ages of 21 years old so that might give
us some insight as to what types of
environmental exposures might be
contributing to autism risk but it's
going to take time to collect that data
so that's that's the problem i know that
you know families have these questions
now they want to know what's caused
their child's autism or how can we you
know inform our relatives who are
thinking about having children of what
to do and what to be careful about but
unfortunately there's not that kind of
information available yet
thinking of people whose families donate
the brains of Alzheimer's okay well they
don't know till they investigate the
brain I understand that but I 21 years
to people who are struggling with a
loved one with autism sounds it hurts
you know it just hurts but I just
thought I'd throw that out because I
think most parents are being
terrifically careful about toxins now
just from if you will commercial Network
casual reading we know where we're not
doing the best work to our children with
toxins so I just hope that perhaps
there'll be something you'll come up
with thank you
the role of vaccines in autism okay I'm
their their development on
neurobiologists and it's very
interesting as a committee made up of
neurologists pediatricians a whole range
of scientists going back and looking at
all this literature and one thing the
only thing you can say is that in some
instances in in one instance for example
there's a sodium channel mutation and if
you give somebody measles mumps or
rubella vaccine that person can develop
epsilon F alep see because they've
already there already susceptible okay
and and if you generalize that and I
firmly believe this but for studying
development for many years there are
susceptibilities we're all born with
right and so you hear about something
something in plastic bottle sore so you
know and and it's possible but it could
only be in you know point 1 percent of
the people so you can drive yourself
nuts trying to raise somebody in a
bubble you know and and that's probably
not good for them to write so it it in a
disease like this it is so complicated
to know what the factors are and the
really only sing and I don't know if you
have statistics on this but early
intervention does help early
intervention and training does help not
for everybody but for many of them
reception outside another gave good time
first of all to just informally talk
with some of the speakers and the
faculty they're here but also if someone
would likely tour an optional tour
you'll be someone outside you will raise
your hand and just go to her and I'm
back here you're interested in a tour
I'll be waiting for you outside and I'll
take you downstairs yes kinda weak
immediately after then you come back
reception thank you see you